so Reuters is reporting some potentially
a pretty major news we learned that
North Korean leader Kim jong-un went to
China Sunday was there until today
earlier today their their 1213 hours
ahead of us on a non official visit and
a picture of the two leaders the chinese
president ji and kim jong-un from north
korea has been tweeted by a Chinese news
agency Xinhua News and this was reported
originally all by Chinese news and has
since been confirmed and as far as is
known this is the first time that Kim
jong-un has left North Korea since he
took over power about seven years ago in
2011 and according to China while in
China president ji and North Korean
leader Kim jong-un have negotiated a
pledge from North Korea to denuclearize
the Korean Peninsula and you will soon
see why that language denuclearize the
Korean Peninsula not just denuclearize
North Korea is very very relevant
language for what may be in Kim Jong
Un's mind here that goes well beyond
just being semantics and this reportedly
took place during a meeting between the
leaders of the two countries and the
immediate reaction was this this must
all be BS but case in point Kim jong-un
has not left North Korea since taking
power so it's all unprecedented the fact
that it sounds hard to believe really
shouldn't tell us too much because we
already know that the trip in and of
itself is sort of historic at least in
the context of Kim Jong Un's reign in
North Korea and there is plenty of
reason to be skeptical right there's
plenty of reason to believe that Kim
jong-un is thinking of what we think of
when we hear about denuclearizing in the
region but the fact that this might be a
thing is more than enough reason to talk
about it and take it seriously
the real caveat here and I alluded to
this a couple minutes ago is that Kim
Jong hoon more than likely a
read - denuclearization of the Korean
Peninsula in theory if all American
troops leave South Korea which just is
not likely to happen right this is
potentially setting up the United States
to be blamed by Kim jong-un for impeding
denuclearization because Kim jong-un now
by saying hey I'm I'm open to
denuclearizing the peninsula which
includes two countries North and South
Korea what does that mean in terms of
how we should interpret it well the
United States military being the
military of a nuclear nation has a saw a
strong presence in South Korea so what
Kim jong-un I believe is effectively
saying here is I'm willing to
denuclearize North Korea if South Korea
is willing to denuclearize in the sense
of getting all military from nuclear
nations out of there meaning United
States troops have to go and it just
seems very difficult to think that
that's going to happen and in fact it's
very likely that this is an attempt not
not a stupid one by the way by Kim
jong-un to take the high ground
politically while he can because there's
this window here where it appears as
though we are going in the direction of
talks that will involve North and South
Korea and the United States potentially
at the end of May of this year just a
couple of months from now there's this
window right now
where Kim can take the political high
ground and say I'm ready to come to the
table which by the way he's always been
willing to do he's always been desperate
to get to the same table as an American
president and I'm willing conceptually
in theory to agree to denuclearize the
peninsula which would more than likely
require the United States to go they
meet South Korea and the u.s. and North
Korea and North Korea says hey we want
peace and stability let's have all
nuclear powers leave the peninsula we
will be nuclear eyes and US troops must
leave Trump overreacts says no and then
who knows what happens and in the
interim of course Donald Trump
completely predictably on Twitter
pushing this as sort of a victory some
unique that he has been able to achieve
tweeting this morning for years and
through many administrations everyone
said that peace and the denuclearization
of the Korean Peninsula was not even a
small possibility now there is a good
chance that Kim jong-un will do what is
right for his people
and for Humanity look forward to our
meeting and this is just the narrative
is so attractive to trump he's so
obsessed with the idea as the sole and
unique Broker of progress in the region
that he if he even understands it is
ignoring it but more than likely doesn't
know nor care to understand that when
Kim talks about the denuclearization of
the peninsula he's talking about Trump
pulling troops and he likes the
narrative Trump does of hey I was
elected all of a sudden Kim jong-un
might do what is right it is more than
likely that Kim jong-un is at least on
the path of playing Donald Trump here
and of course Trump's not just not
knowledgeable enough to understand what
it is that Kim jong-un means by the
denuclearization of the peninsula
yeah presidents always take and receive
credit for favorable world events even
if they had little to nothing to do with
it
right and but I think if you if there
was an exchange where Trump is obnoxious
but North Korea decides to denuclearize
and it turns out the whole peninsula
decides the new denuclearize that's good
for us I think in the end oh yeah I
guess I don't know it's just that that
would include Trump saying yeah we'll
pull all of our troops more than likely
and and that's just not gonna happen
here's something different and very very
funny today's episode of the show is
made possible in part by the donut
trumpet tycoon real estate investing
game which is a hilarious mobile game
for Android and iPhone and it features
my favorite orange real estate investor
or some people call him a tycoon and the
entire thing is a satirical commentary
on capitalism on Donald Trump on the
real estate industry but it's a lot more
than that it's actually a really well
designed and intricate strategy game
which allows for dozens and dozens of
hours of very entertaining gameplay
and it's perfect for anybody who enjoys
business sim
halation games you can buy sell and
trade real world real estate properties
in New York City and all around the
globe you can even buy real world
properties near where you actually live
using your phone's GPS you manage your
real estate portfolio you earn rent from
your tenants you try to avoid multiple
bankruptcies like the real Donald Trump
in his business and I am required to
mention that this game is not endorsed
by Donald Trump lest there be any
confusion about that but it does have a
five-star rating in both the Google Play
Store and the iOS App Store with
thousands of reviews check it out you
can download it for free right now on
Android and iOS and if you're watching
this on youtube you can use either of
the links in the description underneath
the video